then Judd was like he really taught me  something and this is really you ever  get something some somebody something  your therapist told you and you're like  this cost me ten thousand dollars I'm  telling you what to do this is like ten  thousand dollars worth of Show Business  advice right because he was like and  he's so right  uh entertainment's all about surprise  everyone thinks your parents are gonna  like you and not like the dirty people  he was like your mom should be like at  least they had something to say like you  were up there talking about road signs  oh my God it's this satisfying moment  right and it's such a simple principle  but that's one of the that's really ten  thousand dollars worth of appetite right  there